hello and welcome to Playstation
grenades injustice too is a superhero
beat em up in which almost everyone has
super powers and is nigh on impossible
to kill
that's where super moons come into play
and the weirder the better
just ask the flash rod last week
know your sensibly good old Barry can
run so fat that he can go back in time
but he's kind enough to take his enemies
with him showing them ancient Egypt as
close as humanly possible before forcing
his balls to headbutt a dinosaur once
they've been tyrannosaurus rekt it's
back to the present day to meet
themselves the ultimate history lesson
thanks Barry the Gotham fully what Haven
yeah make Aten bed it'll never fly
Catwoman isn't a superhero and does not
have those superpowers so she is bought
to get a little creative with her super
moves that's where her motorcycle and
wit come in to think
dragging her rivals through Gotham
before crushing them under an exploding
mass of metal I bet she found that a
little amusing she has a bit of an
attitude separable terrible
partly you're losing control part of my
charm
Poliquin is less creative but her super
does allow her to bring something
different to proceeding you know a
couple of dyed hair hyenas who like to
chow down on supervillain flesh she's
even got wood for you what a gal Carly's
former love interest the Joker is a
sadistic clown who carries around an
electric chair just in case he gets the
chance to use it to make this overkill
he adds a few sticks of dynamite to
event to lighten the mood no less he
always had a bit of a short fuse
[Music]
from the fiery depths of apocalypse
mixed oxide he likes walks in the park
for supplies I'm sending [ __ ] into
orbit hitting every satellite possible
before administering an almighty
high-five he's a lovely guy wouldn't you
get to know him
[Music]
come to me babe I know your game
I care a man likes me injustice to have
its own gardener in the shape of poison
ivy those green fingers can revive any
failing plant ever seen the Little Shop
of Horrors and wonder what happened to
Audrey to do difficult nothing do you
make me he's alive and well and chowing
down at every opportunity
my grandfather talked about you swapping
pre-show Gould respected speech he said
if I meet you to kill you one of the
most underrated characters in the DC
Universe is Swamp Thing who has a long
and drawn-out history
he's the thing that came out of the
swamp well that was easy
Swamp Thing is a wrecking machine who
hands out a good old fisting in your
dark cave I don't think I meant it like
that so that's it that's seven
ridiculously brilliant super moves in
injustice - what do you think of our
list
seen any others you think deserve to be
here please let us know I imagine from
PlayStation grenade please like and
subscribe if you haven't already and
I'll see you next time